weit in den himmel steigt der rauch
kündet von gewalt und tod von tragödien
anbrennen die stadt hand lang ist nur
ein beispiel von vielen häuser brennen
straßenzüge ganze dörfer überall in
myanmar
internationale beobachter haben keine
zweifel das sind die taten des militärs
es macht jagd auf vermeintliche rebellen
oppositionelle führt strafaktionen
durchsetzt auf angst und schrecken
hunderttausende fliehen über die grenze
nach thailand oder verstecken sich im
eigenen land
mein cousin wurde auf offener straße
erschossen an seiner leiche haben
soldaten dann eine mine befestigt wer
die leiche bergen heute sollte sterben
das war furchtbar
es hat den ganzen tag geregnet und wir
trauten uns nicht die leiche zu holen am
abend haben dann einige versucht den
körper mit einem langen stock zu bewegen
die mine ging sofort hoch zerfetzte den
toten wir haben nur noch leichenteile
zurückbekommen
das auszusprechen diese bilder der
zerstörung aus dem land zu schmuggeln
schon das ist lebensgefährlich
doch es gibt sie noch die mutigen die
unbeugsam in yangon erobern sie die
straße für ein paar minuten eine
flashmob demonstration verabredet über
digitale kanäle und flüsterpost sanität
geht voran schreibt kämpft für
demokratie
dann wird die sache zu heiß schnell
verschwinden abtauchen überleben
irgendwo in yang gon
jenny ted und seine freunde wechseln
regelmäßig ihr versteck sie stehen ganz
oben auf der fahndungsliste des militärs
deshalb bleibt der ort des treffens
geheim doch ihre gesichter zeigen sie
uns
die sicherheitskräfte sind überall wir
müssen sehr vorsichtig sein
aus sorge um uns aber auch für unsere
freunde familien alle die uns
unterstützen das militär schießt es ist
brutal es tötet
und deshalb ist es für uns auch nicht
leicht noch massen proteste zu
organisieren
wir verfolgen also diese geringe taktik
immer wieder flashmobs mit wenigen
leuten
banner werden bemalt für die nächste
protestaktion
kundschafter suchen schon nach einem
geeigneten ort planen die fluchtwege
falls die polizei früher auftaucht als
gedacht so ist der kampf im untergrund
jungen leute sind bereit ihr leben der
revolution zu opfern sie haben alles
aufgegeben ihr zuhause verlassen es gibt
nicht mehr viele die uns beistehen aus
angst aber einige unterstützen uns
zumindest finanziert und wir nehmen auch
das taschengeld dass uns unsere eltern
geben so übernehmen wer
janet ist 27 student die zukunftspläne
die einmal hatte spielen gerade keine
rolle mehr aber kann so eine handvoll
junger idealisten die demokratie retten
sind sie wirklich eine gefahr für das
autoritäre regime der politikanalyst
kinsau green der sich selbst noch traut
eine kritische stimme zu sein meint
schon der gibt der sales auf diese
aktionen halten den glauben an den
widerstand und die revolution am leben
die runter weiß um die effektivität
dieser flashmobs die mehrheit der
menschen wagt nicht sich daran zu
beteiligen aber sie bejubelt dieser
aktion deshalb geht sie runter brutal
dagegen vor sie verhaftet foltert tötet
sogar
mi ann mors militär hat oft genug
bewiesen dass es keine skrupel kennt
seit dem putsch vor gut einem jahr gibt
es erst recht keine grenzen mehr
[Musik]
der starke mann ist general leyen nach
außen präsentiert er sich und die armee
als bewahrer der ordnung als garant für
stabilität und sicherheit die bedroht
gewesen sei durch die demokratischen
kräfte roman sanssouci
jeder weiß dass alles mit einem
wahlbetrug begann und dem versuch
einiger damit die macht an sich zu
reißen das militär sich daher
verpflichtet einzugreifen
die ordnung wiederherzustellen
aber sie widersetzten sich wir mussten
den notstand ausrufen das militär steht
in der verantwortung für unser land
außerhalb des regimes glaubt keiner an
diese legende auf sanssouci ist
inzwischen zu vielen jahren haft
verurteilt worden weitere prozesse
laufen ob die 76 jährige jemals wieder
freikommt
anfangs hatte ihr schicksal die massen
mobilisiert aber das bild der ikone
verliert an strahlkraft
[Musik]
sie hat das machtspiel nicht gut
gespielt das militär war auf alles
vorbereitet sie nicht und als anführerin
musst du vorbereitet sein es geht nicht
darum ob paarung sun tzu chi beliebteste
ich glaube schon dass die jungen leute
jetzt aktiv sind sun tzu chi achten und
ihre freilassung fordert aber ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass sie noch
einmal die führung der
oppositionsbewegung beanspruchen kann
es ist die jugend die den kampf für
demokratie am leben hält es ist die
jugend die dafür ihr leben riskiert auf
den straßen von janna 7 den aufbruch in
eine neue zeit
ja
[Musik]